is there even a slight chance that Obama
times his press conference to interrupt
Donald Trump's Celebrity Apprentice it
was well it was suspiciously amazing
that at the very moments black ninja
gangster was taking care of bin Laden uh
the douchebag Trump was like firing the
Playmate of the Year it was amazing I
mean it just showed the contrast I mean
yeah and honestly if you had to bet your
own money on the to 2012 election tell
me you you'd bet on the Republican at
this point you tell me what personal
income growth is in the 12 months before
voting day and I'll tell you to bet bet
oh really you you think anybody in the
Republican Party could beat him at this
point I think I think if personal income
growth in those 12 months is less than
1% I think he's very vulnerable I think
that's just err one of the one of the
things we know about the way the
American people vote and you don't want
to go too long on this week and your I
hope your the words of your farewell
editorial don't come back to haunt you
but this is a high week for presidents
they also have low weeks right and they
should and they should always remember
remember at the highs III hope President
Obama has the wisdom in the moment of
the high to remember the lows come to
but you wouldn't you wouldn't really
argue with the basic premise of that
which is that when you talk about McCain
saying he wouldn't have gone into
Pakistan when you talk about Obama
saying I would and the this method
versus the other method that one side
plainly had it right and one side didn't
but but would you argue with that
you know snipers don't always get it
right though bill and we have to
remember that you know for all of the
training and all of the experience that
went into this operation that took out
bin Laden it could have all gone
horribly wrong as well so you we just
can we just can't bet on these sorts of
operations time in and time out and I'm
with Jeremy on this you know that that
normalizing these sorts of operations as
if there's somehow a substitute for
actual foreign policy is highly
dangerous not for foreign policy but in
a network
remember that President Obama added
eighty thousand additional hostages to
Pakistani policy to the American
presence in Afghanistan that's what the
that's one of the reasons the reason
that McCain didn't want to said no to
that question was because he was so
worried about the Afghanistan war and
the more worried you are about the
Afghanistan war the more difficult it
the more difficult it is to act against
Pakistan he and we are now all a lot
more it was it test there was a question
on the test and somebody got it right
and somebody got it wrong mirre why
can't we just cook that real about that
somebody answered and somebody answered
B and a was right and you know I mean
what and come on this was like our
Entebbe right wouldn't you say that this
was are things much bigger than Entebbe
it was what bigger than that Tibbie I
would say but I mean pulled off with the
same yeah expertise and you know it
worked we didn't even do it I didn't
think Obama even did anything that
incited a backlash like he didn't kill
all his kids right he could have killed
the bin Laden kids like they would then
the Godfather by saying it M&E was very
calm I think to David's point though I
don't think he had any kind of bravura
or bravado or swagger he was like we did
this we did this at my chuza it was all
in the pronouns though the pronouns were
doing a lot of work that night what I
did what I suggest oh yeah I you know so
oh and then he went on a bit of a
victory lap you know I mean he gets the
credit because if it had gone wrong he
would have got the blame it's not but
let us not forget that it could have
gone wrong and irshad is right you I
think that people who are supporters of
the president want to be very very
careful about taking this week as the
baseline for what is going to be a David
John why can't your kind of balanced
reflective thoughtfulness be the case
for most Republicans while they are
gloating in the downfall of some other
guy like the Democrats or how they think
Obama stupid and just incapable of being
tough because they're not Jewish
I think it has to do with being Canadian
actually I'm not there despite my
idiotic character I I put that in the
hypothetical Joe don't roll tape oh I
said I hope you're not saying that
because that would be that's why I did I
didn't attribute the thought to you yeah
I mean I wouldn't have used the word
idiotic but I'm more with you on that
point right you know so I I was gonna
show this night but before the week
passes this is one reason could you get
a shot of this yeah this is the Weekly
Standard from this week this is one
reason why magazines are going out of
business is because the lead time is too
long this obviously they wrote this and
put this out show it again because it's
just so delicious this obviously was put
out right before Obama's right leading
from behind
yeah there's Obama hiding behind a sand
dune with a camel that's really what his
thing is isn't it but but this is what
I'm but don't normalize this week
because Libya is looking ugly and that
in Afghanistan is looking difficult and
there are a lot of problems ahead and I
don't think you need to gratuitously
oppose the president or belittle him or
described him as an alien to say you
know you've got some real worries about
someone but here's what here's what
William Kristol said in in the editor
that accompanies this a guy who always
wrong about everything he said all the
Republicans have to do is nominate a
real leader a workhorse not a show horse
a steady hand not a flip-flopper a
Profile in Courage
not in cleverness Oh a confident man or
woman with strength and confidence in
defense of Liberty at home and abroad
yeah always trying to avoid the
appearance of relevance every weekly
stick like I'm not funny oh yeah yeah I
mean a little bit of profiles encourages
the leader is alright let's call him
wrong and move on why give them you know
why give him that much credit cuz it
felt good
and because I like don't roll in and
because they don't relent in they glow
and politics dip what yeah but that's
not politician that apart with my side
is wrong your side is right as politics
but when you get into demonizing other
people and making the monsters that's a
different kind of thing and don't forget
before this I agree I would have said
that to Keith Olbermann by the way when
you know he had his the worst persons of
the day or night or whatever it was I
mean he was just as bad as it was no
stop it demonizing Clark okay first of
all worst persons I think we know that
that's a joke that we don't really think
it's the worst person in the world it's
called hyperbole that tired right the
point is it's like sex everybody does it
everybody does it so so why the double
standard and you know sort of we're
waiting out that one side does it but
when the other side does it that's just
I don't think there's hype acting like
this hyperbole on the side of the folk I
would say are the right-wingers who are
demonizing people that's not hyperbole
they actually believe it with religious
fervor they my friend are not so many
people on the left in this country who
believe their own BS as well Oh nobody
human tonight yeah you know what no one
is arguing that the break that the
Democrats are the progressives or the
liberals are perfect in that era they
fall way short right but you are
professing something that I think is
even more dangerous false equivalent of
so yeah Glenn Beck and and and you know
Keith Olbermann are not the same thing
but but one that's the wrong answer
okay I'll concede you I'll concede to
you that it's true yeah that the kind of
vitriol that President Obama encounters
is worse than the president of the trail
that President Bush encounter that's
true it's also true that what President
Bush encountered was worse than what
President Clinton encountered and what
President Clinton encounters was worse
than President George HW Bush George got
worse than clip we got impeach we are on
in terms of the thenar seriously I mean
that i-i've astaire Sharlee that the
idea that the Iraq war was the work of a
cabal of Jews inside the Bush
administration I don't mean what is said
on television and the stalkers in the
rain it's a terrific way but what I
would I worry about is the normalization
of paranoid theories in our politics and
that is worse in every cycle it's true
it's worse now than it was then
it was worse tonight was fundamentally
worst of all done to mentally disagree
with that when Democrats get elected
Clinton and Obama the last two there is
a view on a lot of people on the right
that the election is just illegitimate
from the get-go right and that whatever
we do to remove this person whether it's
birth certificate [ __ ] or finding
them with Monica Lewinsky or whitewater
is justified because we know what's
right for this country and therefore any
way we can get him out is the right
thing and I do not think that happens on
the other side all right
as I said I said that it is not in it we
don't need to show that this is like is
precisely the same as that to show that
we have a problem it was not just radio
and TV talkers who put the Cabal theory
the neocon theory these were former
national security advisers these were
former deputy directors of the CIA these
are some of the most esteemed people in
the land and these were professors at
Harvard and the University of Chicago
and who who put into American discourse
some very poisonous things I think it's
more I think birtherism is worse than
that I agree with that
but that is not a pass for what was done
before and and it is I think pretty that
this revenge drama we've got this Greek
tragedy we've got it will be worse next
time than it is now unless people stand
up to it well I will look I agree with a
lot of what you said but here's the
problem with me is that when you talk
about the Cabal and the kind of
anti-semitic fervor that people
introduce into the conversation
why can't you acknowledge that the stuff
on Obama is the ape stuff and the black
stuff and the witch doctor stuff is as
vicious and as vitriolic and expression
Oh read my site I write about it I write
letters every what I'm saying but
neither
I mean honestly Dave I don't remember a
lot of this Jew stuff that you're
talking about in the mainstream media I
just don't I mean I'm sure look there's
always people you can find the free
nutso saying anything but I mean there
was a lot of people who thought the Iraq
war was a terrible idea and that there
was because Bush wanted to get revenge
for what they did to his daddy and a lot
of other dumb reasons to go to war
I don't remember watch the BBC the
panorama documentary in which I was one
of the people featured this is the
most-watched TV network on the world I
think do you think there's legitimate
criticism of because a lot of this comes
down to this people say you know is
there any legitimate criticism that can
be made of Israel and Israel's be
sentences with no no I'm saying Israel
and Israel's practice which which aren't
which argues which is a substitute for a
lot of conversation the vicious
anti-semitism that you and I would both
disagree with but when we began to talk
about public policy and foreign policy
in its relationship to the State of
Israel or in regard to people who happen
to be Jewish intellectuals making
certain arguments with which we disagree
is there any legitimate space to make
those arguments without getting the tag
or without being anti-semitic look the
Israel Israel's a whole other fine I'm
sorry violation when I started it was
our politics and paranoid theories in
our politics but to this day they relate
to the State of Israel they relate to
Jewish intellectuals they relate I got
one more question from Internet all
right we were wrong on this but um it's
such an interesting week do you think
that Obama should not have released the
photos as he did not or do you think
that because that's a debate that's gone
on always should he release the photo of
the Dead bin Laden I think the short
answer is yes you do
yeah because they exist and they will be
released at some point you might as well
take ownership of them there are
conspiracy theorists all around the
world in Pakistan a country which what
they'll still say it was doctored it was
yeah but I mean you know this I just
would it would not inflame you know it's
a very tough decision but I look I think
these photos are going to come out
anyway and by the way there were 79
people there don't ya they took photos
as well but they were you know the
reason is it's good that I didn't
release it we know what's going to get
released we don't look like we're
involved in trying to thumb our noses so
to speak in the face of the
but by the way bill if Muslims are
serious in claiming that bin Laden
doesn't represent us and never
represented us than releasing those
photos no matter how you know badly he
looks is no reason to feel humiliated so
that's a good Muslim what if what if the
photo comes out and Lindy England is is
next to him going this with the thumbs
up with that in my name or mind you like
blaming your neck adolf munchenhauser
think about all right thank you
everybody we gotta go
[Applause]